life is an unusual
and mysterious phenomenon it is thought
that there
are great many places in the universe
with minimal conditions
necessary for life to originate and
evolve
however as we all know no direct and
irrefutable proof
of there being biological life elsewhere
has been found
apart from our own planet search for
extraterrestrial life forms is high on
the list of priorities in space
exploration
and its object is to give an answer to
the question
that has been exciting the human mind
since times immemorial
are we alone in the universe after all
for biological life to originate and
start evolving
a medley of a great number of factors is
called for
the chief ones are liquid water an
energy source
and a certain chemical diversity apart
from the earth
several more places in the solar system
are potential life-harboring candidates
with mars as the most prospective one
and most closely studied starting from
the recent past
still there are chances of discovering
alien life beyond its orbit too
all it takes is to have a closer look at
the next closest planet to us after mars
if we look away from the sun
[Music]
jupiter is the largest planet in the
solar system
its mass is 318 times that of the earth
this is a gas giant made up mostly of
hydrogen and helium
apart from these methane ammonia sulfur
and nitrogen compounds and water ice
have been detected in its atmosphere
in spite of the diversity of chemical
compounds the possibility of finding
life forms on jupiter itself is
minuscule
what with the absence of any hard
surface high temperatures of the
planet's inner layers and unimaginable
pressure in its interior
biological creatures simply have no
chances of survival
at the same time jupiter boasts quite a
vast array of moons
four of the most well-known ones io
callisto
ganymede and europa were discovered as
far back as in 1609 by galileo galilei
quite close to the moon and mercury in
size they're on the list of the largest
satellites in the solar system
it is also suggested that jupiter
accumulated substantial amounts of
thermal energy due to gravitational
contraction when forming
as a result it is now giving off more of
this energy
than it is getting from the sun that is
why the gas
giant with all the objects orbiting it
may be seen as a curious version of the
solar system in miniature
at first glance jupiter's moons may
appear to have no prospects
in terms of searching for
extraterrestrial life
far from the sun they are encased in ice
and their atmospheres are not
dense however on closer scrutiny
these celestial objects reveal something
excitingly promising
callisto europa and ganymede are highly
likely to have liquid oceans
under the ice shell estimates show that
space
objects with concealed oceans may offer
favorable conditions
for life even if they are much further
from their star than planets like our
earth are from the sun
the thick icy shell on their surface
serves not only as protection against
radiation and meteorite info
but also acts as fairly good thermal
isolation
that is why it is feasible that
conditions inside a massive layer of
water may be good enough for life to
originate
and evolve there these assumptions make
jupiter's satellites some of the most
attractive objects for exploration
within the solar system
and now let's have a closer look at each
of them
ganymede is the largest and most massive
celestial object in jupiter's environs
of all the satellites in the solar
system it is not only the one sporting
the most impressive dimensions
but it also resembles a real planet more
than any other
ganymede's radius measures 2634
kilometers
which is 8 percent more than that of
mercury
as for its mass it equals 1.48
times 10 to the power of 23 kilograms
this is twice the mass of our moon
interestingly ganymede is the only
satellite in our solar system with a
liquid metal core
and its own magnetosphere
processes of nuclear decay take place in
ganymede's interior
this heats the satellite still more with
the average surface temperature 110
kelvin
or 163 degrees celsius below
zero the core on the other hand is
estimated to be as hot as up to 1500
700 kelvin investigations of ganymede's
magnetic field
carried out by the galileo space probe
showed that there may be a multi-layer
sortie ocean under the satellite's icy
shell
as deep down as 200 kilometers or more
the number of layers may reach four
water in each
is of different salinity density and
temperature
with the layers separated from each
other by some ice
spectrographic investigations of
ganymede's surface
show it to have a rather rarefied oxygen
atmosphere
this however isn't an irrefutable proof
of there being biological life on the
satellite
molecular oxygen is likely to form as a
result of the exposure of water ice to
ultraviolet radiation
hydrogen the other product of this
chemical reaction
floats away into space oxygen meanwhile
which is a heavier element settles close
to the surface
apart from large amounts of water ice
other elements found on ganymede's
surface
are carbon dioxide sulfur dioxide
sulfates and some other organic
substances
they may well have originated in the
depths of the subsurface ocean but the
mechanisms of their settling on the
satellite's surface
are still not clear
callisto is another celestial object
potentially just as attractive for life
this satellite is jupiter's second
largest one and lies furthest from it
its diameter measures 4820 kilometers
almost like that of mercury callisto is
encased in an icy shell as thick as 80
to 150 kilometers
and it is highly likely that there is a
salty ocean concealed under it
containing large amounts of ammonia and
other substances
[Music]
the estimates of its depth range from 50
to 300 kilometers
and its temperature is around 251 kelvin
or 21 degrees celsius below zero
according to most models
due to impurities and high pressure the
water in the ocean should remain
in its liquid state below the subsurface
ocean there is bound to be a layer of
ice as thick as around 300 kilometers
and the satellite score made up of water
ice and rocks
lies still deeper down
callisto's surface is pock marked with
craters
spectral analysis of light reflected
from this celestial object
revealed not only water vapor and
silicon rocks
but also ammonia carbon dioxide
sulfur iron and magnesium compounds as
well as stolens
complex organic polymers containing
nitrogen
these brightly colored substances form
on the surfaces of celestial bodies
a result produced by ultraviolet
radiation
callisto happens to lie too far from
jupiter to get more heat from it
besides the tidal influence exerted by
the giant neighbor
isn't enough to deform the satellite
although friction in the process would
heat it up
also most of this body is made up of ice
whereas it is preferable that there
should be solid drugs
which would saturate water with elements
vital for life forms to originate
with the diversity of chemical compounds
here rather modest
and the temperature quite low it hardly
improves chances of life evolving here
still this possibility should of course
not be ruled out yet
the most promising of jupiter's
satellites in terms of searching for
alien life is europa
the smallest of jupiter's four galilean
moons
it is just a bit smaller than our moon
the equatorial temperature on this
celestial body is 110 kelvin
or 163 degrees celsius below zero
at the poles temperatures may drop to 50
kelvin
or 223 degrees celsius below zero
europa is tidally locked to jupiter
facing it with the same side only
however its rotation isn't synchronized
ideally
there are deviations from the calculated
trajectory
this may mean that there is a liquid
layer between europa's surface
and core this assumption is confirmed by
observation of interaction between the
satellite and jupiter's magnetic field
carried out by the galileo space probe
in the late 20th century
apart from that analysis of crevices
europa's surface
is covered with shows that the
satellite's crust moved 80 degrees
with respect to the interior this would
have been impossible without a liquid
layer between them
the massive neighbor exerts a strong
influence over europa by causing
powerful tidal waves in its subsurface
ocean
this way the satellite is heated still
more by internal friction
estimates show that the temperature in
europa's interior is high enough for an
ocean of water to be in liquid state
its depth may reach 100 kilometers and
its volume may be twice
that of the global ocean on our earth
europa is covered with an even layer of
exceptionally smooth and clear
ice the highest elements of relief tower
just
several hundred meters above the surface
the thickness of the icy crust may be
anything from 10 to 30 kilometers
although the satellite surface is
streaked with a whole net of long and
deep cracks
some of them may well reach as deep as
the subsurface layer of water
thus the ice at the bottom of these
ravines is valuable material for
studying the inner makeup of europa
another peculiar feature of this moon is
powerful
ice-cold vapour geezers
they open up only when europa is at its
furthest point from jupiter
with the height of the spurts reaching
as much as 200 kilometers
these giant jets are made up of water
vapour which incidentally is
unexpectedly clean
it is still not known for certain
whether the geysers have anything to do
with the ocean
in europa's interior or they come from
gargantuan lakes
embedded in the satellite's icy crust
today the composition of the subsurface
ocean on the satellite
is estimated by analyzing the ice
covering the inner part of its largest
craters
only a really large object is capable of
breaking the thick layer of the ice
clean through on impact after the icy
crust is broken
the water in the subsurface ocean at the
impact site freezes
and forms the bottom of a crater
spectral analysis of the craters reveals
magnesium
sulfur and ion compounds as well as
hydrogen peroxide and strong acids
this demonstrates that there is a vast
diversity of minerals
in the concealed hydrosphere
europa's atmosphere contains oxygen
which forms as a result of ultraviolet
radiation
interacting with the ice water on the
surface splitting the water into oxygen
and hydrogen
the satellite's atmosphere however is
approximately a trillion times as
rarefied as that of our earth
still according to some estimates
concentration of oxygen
in europa's subsurface ocean should be
sufficient for supporting
single cell aerobic life forms
underwater volcanoes should be their
sources of energy
and food as they saturate water with
sulfur and dine oxides
primitive organisms may attach
themselves to the bottom side of the ice
crust
or swim freely in water it was even
assumed that there may dwell
primitive multicellular organisms in
europa's ocean
however this hypothesis appears to be
rather too presumptuous
in fact there is a great many species on
our earth
which would be able to survive in the
estimated conditions of europa's
subsurface ocean
there are among them not only bacteria
resistant to harsh environments
but multicellular creatures too for
example
tardigrades consequently we cannot rule
out the possibility of primitive life
originating in the depths of this
celestial object of its own accord
unfortunately enough in spite of the
keen interest we have in jupiter and its
satellites
so far they've been investigated only
briefly and that by spacecraft
passing them on their way elsewhere no
landings on the gas giant satellites
have so far been attempted
at the moment the largest planet in our
system is being investigated by the juno
probe
but as soon as in july 2021 it will move
on to studying the galilean moons
the data collected by juno will
undoubtedly be of great importance
and help get to the bottom of processes
taking place in jupiter's system
as for upcoming missions back in 2012
the european space agency announced
starting work on the juice project
or jupiter icy moon explorer the mission
of the project
is to explore in detail the gas giant
itself
as well as ganymede europa and callisto
juice will be launched next year but
will reach jupiter's environs
only in 2029 the mission is scheduled
until the year 2033. if all goes
according to plan
our knowledge about the gas giant and
its satellites will be substantially
expanded
another big research project is nasa's
europa clipper
this automatic probe is planned to lift
off the earth's surface
not later than 2023 and to reach
jupiter's system in 2032
the probe's objective is quite
predictably europa
in contrast to jews it is this celestial
body that clipper is supposed to focus
on
more closely admittedly all these
expeditions are plans for the future
i have no doubt that new valuable and
illuminating data will be collected as a
result
which we will do our best to process and
make new informative videos
our knowledge about the universe grows
by the day and cosmo is happy to bring
you up to speed
if you found this video captivating
enough feel free to hit the like button
and subscribe
if you still haven't done so we would
appreciate it if you shared the link
with your friends who are also into
space and
let's keep in touch
you